excitement
sadness
confusion
[Music]
joy
poi can be used to express a lot of
different kinds of emotions but it takes
some insight to know exactly how to do
it
in this video i'm going to show you some
of the ways that you can make your
spinning reflect your inner world so
that it gets seen by the outer world
drex here from drexfactor poi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
in this video i want to get us beyond
simply doing tricks or transitions to
being in a place where we can actually
express our feelings through our
movement but before we dive in i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard les machinski and
becca
thank you all so very much for your
support from my work and my mission
it has been seven months since i shared
my last video on composing poi
choreography and movement i didn't mean
for it to take so long and i'll work to
make sure that there's a smaller gap
between this and the next video in the
series but i do just want to take a
moment to highlight some of the stuff
that came out of that video because it's
going to be really important here too
fundamentally i think that while poi
tricks transitions and combos are
awesome i also really envy dancers for
their ability to tell a story or express
their feelings through their movement
and i think we could use some of that in
the poi world too like i said in that
last video the thing that i want to see
is poi becoming an extension of the
performer rather than an inanimate
object that is treated as the other
there's no reason that poi cannot be an
extension of everything that we have to
say and as much a part of us as our arms
and feet one of the tools available to
us in the poi dance realm is the
capacity to take different timing and
direction modes as well as poi shapes
and patterns to build and then release
tension
that was the topic of my last video and
i'll link to that down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching on youtube but i
think we can also do more to get
directly to moving our props in a way
that conveys our emotional state to our
audience and that's what i want to
tackle in this video to talk about this
i also want to talk a little bit about
something that's considered pretty
esoteric even among traditional dancers
labon movement analysis now this is a
tool that's used to analyze every and i
do mean every single move that the human
body engages in everything from gestures
to facial expressions and its first
application was understanding the
breadth of what dance could create there
are a lot and i do mean a lot of
different ways that labon analyzes
movement it's so complex that grasping
it fully takes years of instruction and
people sometimes go to school
specifically to learn it but for right
now i want to focus on a single element
of it and that is effort or dynamics of
movement i swear to god this is going
somewhere please stick with me when it
comes to effort labon recognizes four
major categories of the spectrum going
back and forth between two extremes for
each when it comes to an object
traveling through space it can travel
directly between two points in a
straight line or it can find its way
there more circuitously or along a curve
this is direct versus indirect motion
next there's the movement of the body
through time is a movement being
performed quickly or is it being
performed more slowly or in a sustained
fashion there's also the weight of
movement which can range from strong
movements with a great deal of force
behind them to light movements that feel
much more relaxed finally there's the
flow of movement something poi spinners
and flow artists know absolutely nothing
about right here the question is whether
the movement is bounded with a clear
beginning and end or whether it's more
free-flowing like a run-on sentence by
themselves these four aspects of
movement describe a lot of ways that we
can move but what do they have to say
about how we express movement quite a
lot actually because poi have to be
continuously swung around to stay in
motion
we are just a little bit hamstrung in
what we can do with them no movements
can be slow enough that the poi can't
complete being swung over the hand
unless that's our intention and there
are certain movements that are
physically impossible due to gravity
then
but we can still make do with what we
have access to in addition the poi
patterns and tricks most likely to be
useful for our purposes are those that
involve a lot of hand movements in space
from flowers to body tracers and the
like we're going to be mostly out of the
realm of weaves and butterflies for this
so let's start by exploring direct and
indirect motion with poi try taking a
couple tricks that you feel very
comfortable with and explore moving your
hands directly from point to point in
them versus taking an indirect route one
of my favorite ways to explore this is
with zan's diamond zan himself has said
that part of his motivation for
exploring patterns made out of linear
extensions was to add more direct
movement to his spinning and broaden his
palette of movement
and the thing is you can also perform
this pattern with indirect movements as
well taking a closer to third order
motion territory i personally find that
moving my hand directly between two
different points while spinning the poi
can feel very sharp aggressive or
exciting depending on how i tweak it
by contrast moving my hand in an
indirect fashion such as along a curve
changes the feel entirely to become
something more languid relaxed or softer
now it does have to be said that we have
the option of doing direct and indirect
motion with the poi too
but it tends to wind up being just a
little bit more complicated most flower
based tricks involve the use of indirect
movements because quite frankly that's
just what we get when we spin poi
everything is curved
our bodies can be creating direct
movements while the poi are exploring
indirect movements the contrast between
the two can be quite interesting but
some poi tricks do offer us the
opportunity to perform direct movements
for example stalls linear isolations
pendulums horizontal plane tricks and
toroids all present the audience with
more straight as opposed to curved lines
you can play with some very curved flowy
poi tricks before abruptly shifting into
lots of stalls or toroids to change the
feel of what you're doing there's
actually so much to uncover here that
i'll be devoting at least one follow-up
video to it so these are some of the
many ways that direct and indirect
movements can be used with poi
what about how they're performed in time
that is rapid motions versus slower ones
we are a little bit luckier in this
category as the movement of the hands
and poi tends to be aligned when we talk
about the moving in time
if our hands are moving slowly then the
poi are likely moving slowly too and
vice versa moving our hands or poi
rapidly can convey many of the same
emotions we explored with our direct
movements anger and excitement for
example but when we slow things down
other emotions start to emerge
sadness
pensiveness
harmony
and contentment and now that we have two
different categories to work with for
quality of movement we can experiment
with putting them together to make the
emotions expressed through those
movements even more specific when we
talked about indirect movement it was in
service of showing wonder when we're
moving our hands quickly but what if we
move them slowly instead
now those direct movements read is very
calm and serene perhaps even pensive at
times but the excitement comes back when
we speed things up a bit despite the
movements traveling through space in
exactly the same way by the same token
we can revisit our direct movements and
slow them down to make them feel very
labored and tortured expressing
determination or struggle
speeding them up makes them feel angry
once again
see what happens when you alternate
between the two and the range of motions
it helps you inhabit now just to put it
out there there is actually one case
that i can think of that you can
position the poi in hands at opposite
ends of the time spectrum
having the poi move rapidly while your
body moves slowly i experimented with
this in a video i produced last year
trying to pull together elements of
japanese bhuto dance with poi spinning
and the results looked as tortured and
painful as the feelings that i was
trying to express through it
this also involves spinning the poi in a
way that we're usually trained not to
fairly early on so it creates a lot of
tension for your audience and can make
them feel very uncomfortable lately as
i've been playing around with lighter
poi i've honestly been experimenting
much more with the dynamic range of just
how much variation i can put into how i
explore moving with the prop in time
i highly recommend doing this yourself
glow sticks or pod poi are excellent for
this now let's talk about the weight of
how we move this one is really hard to
explore with poi because they require
such specific movements from the hands
wrists and shoulders it can be difficult
to really explore a full range between
strong and light movements here so a lot
of this is going to wind up in other
parts of your body depending on
presentation strong movements can feel
very confident when performed with
direct motion
and like despair when performed within
note the difference between that
strength seeming like it's being driven
by the performer versus it weighing the
performer down lighter movements can
range from feeling relaxed languid
content
spacey or melancholy the lack of weight
can make someone's movement seem
untethered or otherworldly we're not
going to go deep here because we're
close to being done with our treatment
of movement and really cool things
happen when we put it all together
finally we can look at bounded versus
flowier movements bounded movements have
definitive beginning and ending points
note this can easily be done with tricks
that do keep moving but you turn every
bit of them into discrete bits of
movement in themselves
again this can make movement feel very
labored or intense flowier movements
remind me a lot of a note i always used
to get from my dance teacher you are
always arriving they are continuous and
just melt into each other there's a kind
of egalitarianism in the movement here
with no section being more important
than any other flowier movements to me
kind of suggest a kind of comfortability
that comes from being unbounded and
freer with your movement but your
mileage may vary okay so we've got four
different categories of movements that
each work on a binary
when we combine them together we get 16
possible combinations that cover a huge
gamut of human emotion
let's see how direct movement done fast
with strong intention and bounded
movement comes off to me as very
frustrated
[Music]
direct movement done fast with strong
intention and flowier movement comes off
to me as angry
direct movement done fast with light
intention and bounded movement comes off
to me as engaged or focused
[Music]
direct movement done fast with light
intention and flowier movement comes off
as excited
direct movement done slow with strong
intention and bounded movement comes off
as determined
[Music]
direct movement done slow with strong
intention and flowier movement comes off
as haughty or superior
[Music]
direct movement done slow with light
intention and bounded movement comes off
as confident
[Music]
direct movement done slow with light in
tension and flowier movement comes off
as reflective or pensive
[Music]
indirect movement done fast with strong
intention and bounded movement comes off
as overwhelmed
[Music]
indirect movement done fast with strong
intention and flowier movement comes off
to me
as concerned or worried
indirect movement done fast with light
in tension and bounded movement comes
off to me as confused
[Music]
indirect movement done fast with light
intention and flowier movement comes off
as excited or joyous
indirect movement done slow with strong
intention and bounded movement comes off
as struggling
[Music]
indirect movement done slow with strong
intention and flowier movement comes off
as grumpy
indirect movement done slow with light
intention and bounded movement comes off
sad
[Music]
and finally indirect movement done slow
with light intention and flow air
movement comes off as happiness or
contentment
[Music]
there is so much here to work with
now you might not agree with all of my
assessments here there were absolutely
elements of this that i struggled to put
into words and you may find your own
interpretations of many of these types
of movements land differently than mine
that's okay
work with those intentions nonetheless
sometimes the boundaries between these
different ways of expressing emotions
via movement can feel a little blurry
i'm going to strongly suggest you
download one of the many wheels of
emotion that are out there on the
internet just do a quick google search
for wheel of emotion and you'll find
plenty of good guides
they can help pin down emotions that are
seen as opposite or complementary to
each other
in many cases what makes the difference
in expressing them has to do with very
subtle choices in quality of movement
using these techniques you can make a
poi throw feel angry you can make a
contact roll feel fun and exciting you
can make body tracers feel tortured and
depressing or pensive you now have a lot
more options in your toolbox to play
with for a huge variety of poi tricks
i strongly urge you to go forth and
explore all of them
make sure your audience doesn't just
know what tricks you're capable of have
an opinion on them express that opinion
not only does it make your work more
accessible it also makes it more
interesting this one took a lot of work
research and exploration to get to and i
really appreciate my flow circle patrons
on patreon for being my guinea pigs as i
work through a lot of this material
in case you didn't know my flow circle
patrons get a very special private
lesson delivered straight to their email
inbox every week that features ideas i'm
currently working on or drills on the
topic of their choosing you can sign up
for it over at patreon.com
drexfactorpoi if that sounds like a good
time to you
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
please leave a like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find it
and help my channel grow this video
would not be possible if not for the
wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description help to
make this video and all the videos on my
channel possible
thank you one and all for your support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube
there you can access a whole host of
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
if you dug this video and you'd like to
see more like it it is the second video
in a series in which i'm trying to
summarize everything i know about poi
dance from the past few years and i will
link to the full playlist of videos in
this series both down in the description
as well as up on screen if you're
watching on youtube
thanks so much for watching and make
sure you get outside to dance with your
poi today i'll see you with a new video
real soon
take care